Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A neural network is a very loose model of
the human brain that we can program in a computer,
or it's perhaps more appropriate to say
that it is inspired by our knowledge of the
inner workings of a human brain.
Now, let's note that artificial neural networks
have been studied for decades by experts,
and the goal here is not to show all aspects,
but one intuitive, graphical aspect that is
really cool and easy to understand.
Take a look at these curves on a plane. These
curves are a collection of points, and these
points you can imagine as images, sounds,
or any kind of input data that we try to learn.
The red and the blue curves represent two
different classes - the red can mean images
of trains, and the blue, for instance, images
of bunnies.
Now, after we have trained the network from
this limited data, which is basically a bunch
of images of of trains and bunnies, we will
get new points on this plane, new images,
and we would like to know whether this new
image looks like a train or a bunny. This
is what the algorithm has to find out.
And this we call a classification problem,
to which a simple and bad solution would be
simply cutting the plane in half with a line.
Images belonging to the red regions will be
classified as the red class, and the blue
regions as the blue class. Now, as you see,
the red region cuts into the blue curve, which
means that some trains would be misclassified
as bunnies.
It seems that if we look at the problem from
this angle, we cannot separate the two classes
perfectly with a straight line.
However, if we use a simple neural network,
it will give us this result. Hey! But that's
cheating, we were talking about straight lines.
This is anything but a straight line.
A key concept of neural networks is that they
create an inner representation of the data
model and try to solve the problem in that
space. What this intuitively means, is that
the algorithm will start transforming and
warping these curves, where their shapes start
changing, and it finds, that if we do well
with this warping step, we can actually draw
a line to separate these two classes. After
we undo this warping and transform the line
here back to the original problem, it will
look like a curve. Really cool, isn't it?
So these are lines, only in a different representation
of the problem. Who said that the original
representation is the best way to solve a
problem?
Take a look at this example with these entangled
spirals. Can we separate these with a line?
Not a chance. But the answer is - not a chance
with this representation. But if one starts
warping them correctly, there will be states
where they can easily be separated.
However, there are rules in this game - for
instance, one cannot just rip out one of the
spirals here and put it somewhere else. These
transformations have to be homeomorphisms,
which is a term that mathematicians like to
use - it intuitively means that that the warpings
are not too crazy - meaning that we don't
tear apart important structures, and as they
remain intact, the warped solution is still
meaningful with respect to the original problem.
Now comes the deep learning part. Deep learning
means that the neural network has multiple
of these hidden layers and can therefore create
much more effective inner representations
of the data. From an earlier episode, we've
seen in an image recognition task that as
we go further and further into the layers,
first we'll see an edge detector, and as a
combination of edges, object parts emerge,
and in the later layers, a combination of
object parts create object models.
Let's take a look at this example. We have
a bullseye here if you will, and you can see
that the network is trying to warp this to
separate it with a line, but in vain.
However, if we have a deep neural network,
we have more degrees of freedom, more directions
and possibilities to warp this data. And if
you think intuitively, if this were a piece
of paper, you could put your finger behind
the red zone and push it in, making it possible
to separate the two regions with a line. Let's
take a look at a 1 dimensional example to
see better what's going on. This line is the
1D equivalent of the original problem, and
you see that the problem becomes quite trivial
if we have the freedom to do this transformation.
We can easily encounter cases where the data
is very severely tangled and we don't now
how good our best solution can be. There is
a very heavily academic subfield of mathematics,
called knot theory, which is the study of
tangling and untangling objects. It is subject
to a lot of snarky comments for not being
well, too exciting or useful. What is really
mind blowing is that knot theory can actually
help us study these kinds of problems and
it may ultimately end up being useful for
recognizing traffic signs and designing self-driving
cars.
Now, it's time to get our hands dirty! Let's
run a neural network on this dataset.
If we use a low number of neurons and one
layer, you can see that it is trying ferociously,
but we know that it is going to be a fruitless
endeavor. Upon increasing the number of neurons,
magic happens. And we now know exactly why! Yeah!
Thanks so much for watching and for your generous
support. I feel really privileged to have
supporters like you Fellow Scholars. Thank you, and I'll see you next time!